el lista tucumán es una fiel
simpatizante de keiko fujimori y no duda
de su voto el próximo 11 de abril
elisa disfruta tener como amuleto a un
panfleto con la imagen del expresidente
alberto fujimori quien fue condenado a
25 años de cárcel por violación de
derechos humanos y me consiguieron aquel
valor verdad porque me identifico mucho
con la señora que hay con la parte que
es mujer como ya sabemos sé que en este
si es que llega a ganar no nos va a
apoyar muchos acusan a la hija del
expresidente alberto fujimori de haber
dilapidado al vacío en fujimorista que
diversos analistas calculan en un 30%
del electorado peruano consideran que
las crisis políticas que ocasionó al
poner en jaque a los expresidentes pedro
pablo kuczynski y martín vizcarra
respectivamente le generan un elevado
anti voto su estrategia es conquistar a
los electores indecisos y así pelear una
segunda vuelta al candidato es el
momento más opcionado yonhy lescano
estamos disputando el segundo lugar
le estamos poniendo mucha energía y
mucha alegría a pesar de toda la
situación tan dramática por la que está
atravesando nuestro país la pandemia del
cobi 19 golpeó duramente al perú
diversos sectores consideran que va a
ser muy difícil que la lideresa
opositora llegue a la segunda vuelta no
sólo por la excesiva cantidad de
candidatos a la presidencia sino también
por su complicada situación penal del
fujimorismo tal vez en estas elecciones
consiga unos 10 congresistas en un
congreso unicameral de 130 bancas en la
elección anterior tuvo 73 congresistas
la diferencia es abismal la caída es
bastante nos llega a extinguirse a
desaparecer pero si queda muy reducido
en su fuerza política elisa hecho cupo
mano se desanima sabe que mientras otro
fujimori lleven las riendas del
movimiento político se creará una nueva
generación de fujimori lovers